globalization wealth and supermarkets
these three ingredients are why most of
us can eat whatever we want whenever we
want
but as the temperature of planet earth
cranks up some of our favorite dishes
might soon be off the menu
the world is running out of chocolate
because of disease drought new markets
the demand for cocoa beans is expected
to outstrip supply by an additional 1
million tonnes every decade for the
foreseeable future
in just six years the price of cocoa
increased by 87
higher temperatures and bad weather
brought coffee rust fungus to
plantations
combined with a severe drought this year
in the world's biggest producer brazil
prices have skyrocketed
in africa the number of regions suitable
for growing coffee is predicted to fall
anywhere from 65 percent to 100
as the climate warms
temperatures will likely reduce crop
yields heat increases the rate of growth
but this in turn can reduce the time
that seeds have to grow and mature throw
in the demands of a growing global
population and food prices could rise by
up to 84
by 2050
and our oceans won't escape either
catches in some areas of the tropics are
projected to fall by between 40 and 60
percent according to the un
rising co2 leads to ocean acidification
which most fish are slow to adapt to
many of us may be forced to change our
diets in our lifetimes simply due to the
increased costs of the goods we buy
and if we can think beyond our next meal
climate change experts say food
shortages will likely cause political
instability and war